[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Elizabeth Nugent she is an assistant
professor of political science and her
research explores the political
psychology of religion and repression in
the Middle East
professor Nugent uses a variety of
survey voting archival and interview
evidence in her work and incorporates a
mixture of methodologies to analyze this
data today we'll talk with professor
Nugent about her book project after
repression identity and polarization in
democratic transitions
welcome professor Nugent thanks so much
for having me so let's begin with an
overview of your book project tell us
about it great so the book project looks
both historically at the development of
polarization under the previous regimes
in Egypt in Tunisia and also looks at
how polarization during the transitions
affected kind of two aspects of the
transitions again I'm talking about you
know after 2011 the Arab Spring
uprisings kind of the level of effective
polarization so how much the actors who
were in charge of negotiating these very
important transitions how much they
liked each other how much they could you
know get along and then preference
polarization which had to do with
different you know opinions and
positions about things like the
Constitution transitional justice kind
of these core aspects of democratic
transitions and what I find is that the
way in which repression data did not
target these different kinds of actors
that are in charge of the transition
effects the level of effective and
preference polarization so it departs a
little bit from or actually quite a bit
from much of the literature which looks
at democratic transitions or excuse me
polarization in democratic settings
where there's not that same level of
polarization
excuse me repression
and so it's a new theory in many ways
looking at the ways in which the
repression that defines authoritarian
regimes conditions
you know patterns of polarization and
preference formation okay and let's
define the term polarization just so
we're all on the same page right so the
way that I use that in my book it has
these two aspects so effective
polarization and then preference
polarization and I think of these things
as the extent to which groups like each
other how they get along and then the
extent to which groups disagree on
matters of substance so this comes you
know more out of the literature in
American politics where there is this
differentiation between you know
effective polarization where there's
something about feelings towards an out
group and then preferences and what I
find is both are really important even
if you have agreement and hate each
other it's sometimes hard to compromise
if you really like each other but
disagree quite a bit it's also hard to
compromise so these two different
aspects end up being really important in
tandem and what led you to write the
book yeah so I started graduate school
in 2011 I'd been traveling to the Middle
East and working on the Middle East
since 2005 as an undergraduate I went to
Cairo for a summer and it kind of
changed the course of my life at the
time what was happening was called the
kite in hindsight it's been called the
Cairo spring so there was this uptick in
mobilization people demanding certain
democratic rights and the state the
Egyptian state responded quite heavy
handily to this and since then you know
the way in which authoritarian regimes
and the repressive environment affect
political actors has been an interest of
mine when I started my dissertation in
2011-2012 I was interested in
polarization I hadn't quite connected it
with this interest in repression yet but
the more that I you know I went I went
back to Egypt I started working in
Tunisia the conversations I was having
with people really focused on this idea
of you know joint victimhood or you know
singular victimhood depending on the
country in Egypt you have a case where
the Brotherhood the Muslim
was targeted much worse than other
opposition groups in Tunisia you have
what I call a widespread repressive
environment everyone was in jail
together everyone was an exile together
and these stories just started emerging
where this was clearly foundational to
what came later and so why Tunisia and
why Egypt yeah so this is always a big
question of political science how you
choose your cases and my colleagues and
I sometimes joke sometimes you just
really like the country Egypt I you know
have a soft spot for it's been the place
I studied Arabic I spent quite a bit of
time there before I started my PhD but
Egypt in Tunisia were the first two Arab
Spring cases to go essentially so a long
term dictator and Tunisia resigned in
January 2011 in February 2011 the long
term dictator in Egypt resigned and you
know you know in many ways they had very
similar starts they were early cases
there was unprecedented mass
mobilization these to dictators resign
and then within three years they were in
very vastly different situations so
Tunisia was holding a next round of
elections it's passed the Constitution
you know it still has major security
issues and other you know
democratization is not an easy process
but it was continuing down that path and
in Egypt there was a coup and almost a
complete reversion back to
authoritarianism and so the combination
of the similarities at the beginning and
the divergent paths made it you know the
kind of puzzle you want to try to
explain so I am curious about your
methodology did you use the same
techniques in both countries or did you
mix it up tell us about that yeah so the
main methodology is based quite a bit on
you know qualitative evidence so this
includes over a hundred and twenty
interviews that I did with members of
the Opposition in both Egypt and Tunisia
in Egypt it was a little bit more
difficult in Tunisia I went to the
country I was there for about six months
doing these interviews it's not a
particularly large country so
you know between tunas and and some of
the major cities I was able to get a
good representative sample of the people
I wanted to talk to and I found people
quite open to talking about how their
experiences of prison and exile had
shaped them men and women or primarily
men mostly men just you know as a
function of who was in right politics
although there is quite a bit of
interesting work coming out about wives
of politicians who were also repressed
kind of as an extension of their husband
and then also female activists who had
been you know working under the previous
regime in Egypt because of the coup most
of the Muslim Brotherhood members have
either been arrested or you know have
fled to different parts of of the
country and so I didn't excuse me of the
globe and so I did interviews in
Istanbul in London to try and get you
know again a representative sample of
the kinds of people that I was
interested in how did you how did you
find them in Turkey and the other places
yeah so having worked on the Brotherhood
and Islamists more generally for a
couple of years now it was kind of
starting with one person and then what
might be called a snowball sample where
they introduce you to other people I
contacted a few lawyers I you know blind
tweeted at people today if they were
available but I think one thing that I I
felt as I was doing the the work was
that once I had a positive experience
with someone where you know they felt
like their story was being listened to
they were then more likely to recommend
you know someone else a friend or a
colleague do an interview with me as
well to get more of the story like I I
think people like to be listened to I
think they like to matter and these were
extremely traumatic formative
experiences and you know what I think is
great about you know the way that the
book has kind of played out is that it
highlights those experiences of
suffering and put some kind of meaning
onto it so I I think that was part of
why it ended up being maybe easier than
I thought although it was not easy
but once you know one person had a good
experience they were willing to
recommend me to someone else so I'm
curious based on your research did you
find similar things in both countries or
were they different in some way yeah so
they ended up being different
so in Tunisia as I mentioned the way
that the previous regime the Ben Ali
regime had repressed its opposition was
what I call in the book a widespread
repressive environments oh you know
communist Islamist leftists of different
sorts centrist anyone who was opposition
was working in opposition to the regime
would be arrested and targeted and so
you end up with very different kinds of
people very representing different kinds
of groups in jail together in exile
together quite a few of them ended up in
France and other European countries
there's also just a similarity of
experience so even if you know an
Islamist and a communist aren't in jail
together they were probably in very
similar circumstances their families
suffering in the same way and what I
find is that that creates some kind of
you know collective identity that
bridges across these different
opposition identities in Egypt there's a
it's a different story so the Mubarak
regime really just targets the Muslim
Brotherhood and it's not to say that
there isn't repression of other groups
but the Brotherhood certainly gets it
worse and more consistently worse and
why do you think that is yeah so that's
a big big question I guess of endogenous
we couldn't political science I'm
looking I'm now working on a project
with two other researchers at Yale
looking at basically this question why
do regimes repress in different ways and
we look at colonial investments and kind
of you know pre-independence investments
in things like the police in the
military which seem to have these
long-term downstream effects but the
idea is that you know depending on what
you inherit in terms of intelligence or
police capabilities determines how how
you can repress so you know the the
British system really leaves the
Egyptians with the ability to
distinguish between real and non real
threats
as a result they can kind of economize
and target the group that's actually a
threat the French system ends up leaving
in place a very diffuse and maybe not so
effective you know Intelligence Agency
and and institutions that are really
spying on each other rather than their
opposition and so you end up with an
intelligence agency that can't
distinguish between real and fake
threats so it's kind of everybody ends
up being repressed so that's a little
bit beyond what the book talks about but
it's it's always the logical question of
why is this different and it's I think
it's a really interesting question too
so I'm curious in in the when you're
doing the research and talking to people
what kind of questions are you asking
them yeah so just because it seems you
know very you know emotionally driven
kind of question right and I should say
these are long interviews so it's not
something where I show up at someone's
house and ask them so tell me about the
time you were tortured what I try to do
is start with basically the beginning of
their political lives so how did they
get interested in politics a lot of
times it has to do with a personal
experience or their parents and it's
probably you know 30 to 45 minutes into
a conversation about the narrative they
want to tell me of their life but then
we get into some of these you know more
difficult experiences so yes starting
with you know how did you get involved
often something will come up I was
arrested you know when I was politically
active in college or you know this
happened to me when I was young and that
kind of opens the door to starting to
ask about that and then you know what's
interesting too is that once that door
is open and once you've started talking
about kind of personally interesting
things they're also more willing to talk
about some of these other effects so the
effects on their wives the effects on
their children you know the way in which
their friendships were changed so most
these interviews were quite long three
four hours in people's homes in places
where they felt comfortable to talk
about this kind of you know deeply
personal experience
okay and based on your research what are
the implications for Tunisia and Egypt
yeah so the immediate implication was
you know the divergence we currently see
in Egypt in Tunisia so Tunisia as I
mentioned was capable of bringing
together it's old opposition they passed
a new constitution it did take three
years but they did it they held first
elections they've now held municipal
elections there's another set of
election scheduled for next year so you
know by political science standards
they're doing
all the things you need to do to get
into the next stage of democratic
consolidation in Egypt you know it's a
completely different story again there
was a coup there's been a reversion to
authoritarianism and so the book links
experiences a repression to these
developments through polarization so you
know a widespread repressive regime made
a case where there was less polarization
they were more willing and able to work
together on these important decisions
whereas in Egypt you have this targeted
repressive environment there was just
never that same level of cooperation or
agreement and it's really devolved since
2013 since the coup the Brotherhood at
this point is banned as a terrorist
organization as I mentioned you know
quite a few of their members are in jail
at this point I think up to 40,000
members so you know I what I find
interesting is how these things are
really linked to the historical legacies
of the authoritarian period right you
know I'm just thinking about Egypt in
particular and how the Brotherhood was
specifically targeted and I'm wondering
if that has a chilling effect on other
groups in Egypt saying hey you know if
we you know tried to uprise or form
together a group that they would you
know the regime would crack down on them
as they did on the Brotherhood yeah I
mean do you think there's any kind of
thing like that going on yeah at the
moment it there's definitely a chilling
effect the current regime I think has
broken out of even the mold
you know previous authoritarian regimes
in Egypt at last year during the 2018
presidential elections it arrested all
candidates running against the president
kind of departed from the targeted
repressive regime as its reconsolidated
what's interesting is that during the
Mubarak period the way that targeted
repression worked was that it was also
co-opting the other groups so while it
was you know arresting the Brotherhood
it was also permitting the leftist to
exist and published their newspaper so I
think they were trying to combat that a
little bit by getting buy-in from
leftists and secular opposition groups
okay so ultimately what do you conclude
yeah so what I conclude you know
academically it focuses quite a bit on
the importance of it you know
considering the legacies of repression
how this conditions political identities
and you know how this very specific
experience of repression can polarize or
you know bring together a political
society I don't know that I have any
policy implications or you know
conclusions more generally it's Egypt is
unfortunately a very sad case at this
point and I think in Tunisia you see as
much as this mattered you know my
argument and polarization and
experiences that created this you know
narrative of joint victimhood it did
matter quite a bit for that initial
period which is crucial for
democratization but it's still politics
so there you know Tunisia continues to
have its own set of of issues friends of
mine from Tunisia you know when I refer
to it as a success story they're like we
still have huge economic problems we
still have security issues so you know
it's a messy process but what I try to
highlight in the book is how these
specific legacies are very important to
consider mm-hmm okay thank you so much
for being here today and sharing some of
your work thank you for more information
about professor Nugent and her research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan sin
for international and area studies at
Yale
you